well the Duke and Duchess of Sussex have  already confirmed they're not spending  Christmas at Sandringham this year very  in Canada having some family time on a  six-week break but Harry has embraced  the festive spirit and recorded a  special special message for children  who've lost parents in the British Army  telling them they'll never be forgotten  ho ho ho  hi guys everyone it's Corey's little  soldiers I hope you're having an amazing  time  I hear there's 190 of you there this  year so please cause as much chaos as  humanly possible losing a parent is  incredibly hard but I know that every  single one of you by helping each other  out that you will have an amazing future  your parents they will never be  forgotten and you will never be  forgotten have a fantastic Christmas and  a Happy New Year